what's going on guys this is Rob and if
you're enjoying the content that I'm
uploading onto my channel then feel free
to subscribe and you can also offer
suggestions on topics and characters and
storylines and whatnot that we can have
discussions on later on in this channel
you can breathe you can blink
you can cry hell you're all gonna be
doing that you know why you're gonna be
doing that because we are covering the
first volume of the origin of negan
America fan boy I'm so hyped right now
okay so negan is hands down like one of
the best comic book villains in the
history of comic books I'd like
literally to get myself high for this I
went back and I watched the the scene of
like knee and speech oh by the way you
guys need to watch the uncensored scene
you'll find that down in the description
dude it's like it's pure comic-book
negan it is amazing what what happens
like it's all kinds of cussing and
swearing which the MS the negan that we
all know and love so negan is stood out
it's just like hey I mean in all
seriousness negan is stood out as like
the premiere villain of The Walking Dead
so far just in terms of how he relates
to people how brutal he is I mean he's
one of my favorites up to this point but
what Robert Kirkman is doing right now
is he's writing the origin of vegan in
two volumes the first one is six issues
the second is six issues but they're
supposed to span over the course of a
year so the second volume won't be done
in two like August of next year but I
couldn't wait so I figured I would bring
you guys the first half of this which is
really just negan learning about
everything and figure out what's going
on but his story is also really tragic
too so initially we pick up with him in
what seems to be in the garage of his
house and he's actually playing
ping-pong with a couple of students and
he's just as vulgar as he always was
like he's just as boorish and as
obnoxious as he always was in terms of
cussing at people and so on and so forth
but the funny thing is that these are
kids these are just you know small young
kids that are part of this a part of
this class because he's a gym teacher
and so his wife Lucille shows up and
she's like what were you thinking like
these parents are calling me telling me
you're cussing at their kids like your
role models so you have to be role
models for these kids and this is kind
of the cool thing is because Meegan
before the zombie outbreak before we
first met him the fact that he was a
teacher is mind-blowing he was educating
kids you know great if he was educating
kids on like softball and and kickball
which I think are excellent courses to
take I would take a class on kickball
I'm gonna be amazed
the strategies for kickball had be
awesome but you know the fact that he
was so relatable is interesting now the
funny thing about him is that he's like
this weird dichotomy you know when his
wife initially starts talking to him she
passes out she collapses and he ends up
rushing her to the hospital the other
half of this is that while he's in the
hospital and while they're talking to
the doctor they're suddenly met with
some extremely bad news and the news
that they get is not initially given to
us instead we actually pick up with
negan while he's cheating on his wife
now we don't really get the name of this
woman it's just some woman that he's
with but we learn that his wife actually
has cancer here now this is important
for negan's characters so because of the
fact that he's coming to a head here the
reason why I said he had kind of a weird
dichotomy is because he seemed very very
selfish she seemed very self-centered he
seemed for all intents and purposes like
a total jerk but the fact that his wife
is dying seems to refocus his priorities
and that status quo I mean that's like
that's one of the reasons why Kirkman is
so good when it comes to writing
characters is because that always
happens you know when a person is faced
with death uh it focuses it reshapes
their priorities what they're willing to
die for what they're willing to lie for
and what it does is it puts negan in a
mindset and it puts us in the mindset as
a reader that he's a tragic guy you know
that he's not just some dude who's just
a dick and he's always been a dick and
then he was a dick before the apocalypse
and he was a dick after the apocalypse
he said he was just a dick with power
like he's a guy that just had really bad
experiences knowing that his wife is
dying there's a crushing sensation now
he doesn't
initially let this on instead the woman
that he's with you know really just kind
of reads in the riot act and tells him
to leave it's the follow-up to this that
makes it such a huge deal because he
basically tells his wife that he ended
the affair now there doesn't really seem
to be any indication here that she knew
about it instead it seems like she
didn't the fact that she's kind of taken
by surprise in the sense that she's like
why did you decide to break this to me
now now this could be taken one of two
ways it could be that she always knew it
could be that she always had an
underlying suspicion that her husband
was cheating on her because it you know
I've never really been in a boat where
that's happened as a major thing but
from what I understand you know people
who are cheating on their significant
others tend to grow a little bit distant
just because of the fact that their
focus is not on their significant other
it's on the person they're cheating with
and so maybe there was some distance
between the two maybe they want as close
as they used to be but maybe she sensed
there was something going on maybe she
didn't you know but this is kind of the
cool thing is because
allows our imagination to run wild it
allows us to look between the panel's a
kind of ask this question what was going
on behind the scenes in their marriage
now in all honesty I would have liked
for Kirkman to focus a little bit more
on this but instead he doesn't this is
actually kind of a cool thing what he
does is he focuses on the better half of
negan yes he still he still vulgar yes
he still cusses but he's caring for his
wife not only that he's a grieving
husband his wife is dying and he does
what he can to make sure she's taken
care of he does what he can to make sure
that her needs are tended to but not
only that she has a strength of
character that he doesn't have because
while she's in the park while she's
feeding birds he's having an emotional
breakdown now of course this all
eventually gets to the point where his
wife is in the hospital and it's really
the last moments of her life but this
coincides with the start of the zombie
apocalypse now something that I want to
point out here because a lot of people
have asked this question down in the
comments section love you love ask do we
know how the zombie apocalypse started
no and Robert Kirkman has explicitly
stated on a multitude of occasions that
he has no intention of exploring that in
the comics now this is where fear The
Walking Dead comes in because fear The
Walking Dead isn't there's no colorful
counterpart to that there's no comic
equivalent to that that's a totally
isolated standalone idea that involves
the Walking Dead universe that may or
may not cross over with the Maine
Walking Dead series but it's kind of out
there is kind of a satellite title
that's just sort of floating around in
the solar system where I guess the
galaxy of The Walking Dead and the idea
is that in that show these as far as I
understand we're supposed to get some
sort of explanation but again the shows
are Robert Kirkman's way of correcting
things that he wish he'd done in the in
The Walking Dead comics and so I imagine
at this point it would really be too
late to do an origin story but even if
he did you know do an origin story of
how the zombie apocalypse started the
problem with that is it would there
would be light at the end of the tunnel
it would be like okay well they know
what caused it then they can find a cure
for it and it would take away from the
effects of the characters it would take
away from the bleakness that there is no
end to this zombie apocalypse it's just
going to be a part of society from now
on and although here all the characters
can do is just sort of work with all if
I've been saying heroes before but if I
have their heroes they're their heroes
Rick is my hero so I guess it works but
the fact remains here that with his ami
apocalypse you know emerging around the
time that his wife's dying the most
logical scenario happens in the sense
that we of course have people stepping
in say hey man you got to get out of
here you got
you gotta go and initially you know he
tends to his wife says no I'm not
leaving her here I'm not leaving her on
her own more than that
vegan has the same reaction that
everybody else did negan has a reaction
that all this is going to blow over now
the cool thing about this is that this
ties almost directly in line with Shane
because Shane in the comics was very
difficult not really very different but
his motivations were different from the
TV show don't get me wrong in the TV
show why Jon Bernthal was mind blowing
[ __ ] he was an incredible Shane but in
the comic books in the early days Shane
was convinced the government was going
to save them like he was so convinced
the government was going to step in the
government was going to come through it
was going to kill the zombies and
everything was going to go back to the
way it was before even if there's only
in the very beginning even if it's only
in these these small moments here you
know negan believes that all this is
just going to pass through it's just
some plague or just some infection
surely that the CDC or the World Health
Organization or somebody's working on
this right now
don't find a cure things that go back to
normal and his wife will be able to you
know experience her last few moments in
peace but the problem here is that while
he's talking to her she passes away now
while she passes away or at least after
she passes away of course negan's kind
of looking out the window to see what
happens and his wife reanimates his wife
comes back as a zombie now in terms of
the story itself this is actually the
first time we learned that his wife's
name is Lucille and so of course in the
county books we know by virtue of little
bits and lives that that he named his
baseball bat after his wife and he gave
it his wife's personality which is why
he talks about his baseball bat being
named Lucille is named after his wife
that's why he talks about his baseball
bat as if it's a person because in his
mind it's his memory or I guess the the
memory of his wife living on now it's
also kind of really messed up that like
his wife the memory of his wife
continues on by smashing people's heads
in but I'm not going to complain because
they're amazing moments but the idea
here is that you know he doesn't really
know exactly what's going on he doesn't
fully understand what's happening now of
course she collapses and you know and
she simply falls onto the ground and
he's still trying to understand the
situation he's still trying to grasp
everything that's going on now the cool
thing is that the heat doesn't actually
kill her he doesn't do anything to her
but the other half of this is that the
indication seems to be that he does
start to figure out what's going on what
Kirkman does
The Walking Dead this is one of the
reasons why this is so cool he treats
zombies as if there's something that
people have always known about people
always know like they know the concept
of zombies the zombie movies have been
around forever and ever and ever you
know it really all started with George a
Romero's Night of the Living Dead in
1968 I think it was or 63 maybe 65 1960
something you know and then it just kind
of took on a life of its own we got all
these different zombie movies you know
Day of the Dead and Dawn of the Dead and
you know so on and so forth the idea is
that once Megan sees her and realizes
what she is he says okay my wife is a
zombie my wife is reanimated and so he
simply just leaves her he simply just
walks away
you know leaves her to her fader just
leaves her to be a zombie but once he
gets out into the lobby he finds also a
young boy who's currently being set upon
by some zombies and of course the
question that we have to ask now is will
negan step in and will negan save this
kid well of course he does because he's
needy and it's actually really cool you
know getting in and saving this kid's
life it shows us that negan is still
very human in terms of how he views the
world but more so than that you know
it's it's this this idea that for him
he views himself as somewhat of a savior
you know in the sense that there are
people out there that cannot cope with
these situations on their own and his
idea is to help them get past this as
best he can in terms of his own survival
and helping them survive the other half
of this is that what he kills these two
zombies in his mind it doesn't initially
rationalize to him that he killed
zombies in his mind it's I just killed
two people now of course this kid you
know says hey look man like you can't
kill folks who are already dead you know
this this guy's this guy's a zombie I
mean these guys were zombies and there's
nothing we can do here so this is why I
say Kirkman bounces back and forth
between the idea of me and realizing
that his wife was a zombie or maybe not
realizing she was a zombie but if there
was any doubt up to this point this
doubts been eradicated when this kid
says yeah man
these are zombies like these are zombies
running around this place you know these
are zombies killing people like if you
kill them that's fine because they're
gonna kill you if you don't and so after
taking you know a few moments and after
talking to this kid about his wife you
know after taking a few moments of rest
ultimately negan in this kid basically
set off and the idea is what happens
next you know where do they go from here
what situations do they run into you
know is negan or any given to this kid
going to go on and eventually found the
Savior's you know is this kid going to
die before that happens some of that
story's already being told at the
but again because this is the first
volume we're gonna in this video here
but uh but yeah like this is actually a
really cool story because it shows that
Nick in history is tragic
negan has a tragic past he's not just
some terrible guy who continued his
terrible ways when he became leader of
the saviors instead he was just a guy
who was struggling and his wife died and
it's it's tough but if you guys are new
here to comest explain make sure you
guys hit the subscribe button to become
part of the robb core check out my
Walking Dead videos every Sunday if you
guys like this video make sure you drop
a like and leave a comment down below
let me know what you guys think about
about this you know let me know how you
guys feel about this so uh yeah I will
catch you all later peace